those who are familiar and those who are
comfortable with python as a coding
environment can opt for python course
and those works
comfortable with r can opt for our
courses so again you will
get get an introduction to how you are
going to access big data
in in our environment and um uh
like um basic um
understanding of what is the environment
in our studio or our coding environment
and what are the different
different
tools and different
operators and different uh
symbols that we need to understand from
our uh from a coding point of view it is
uh
it is little bit easier to understand a
python code than to understand on our
code but
a tremendous support and excellent
visual
visualization platforms for r actually
makes
are one of the r and python together
right but are slightly uh more used
platform for uh bioinformatics data
analysis but python is also catching up
uh in that aspect so uh we will again
start with loading data into r and how
you can load the data visualize the data
for example study the structures of the
data summarize the data so um
you can learn a lot about the data just
by uh
making or printing out first few lines
of the data so all of these
will be
covered in the first session so in the
second session again we are going to
introduce two working with uh nucleotide
or dna sequences in r in an aim for you
to understand how to perform or how to
use a comparative
sequence comparative comparison methods
using r as a tool so that you can
generate an appreciation for
how to uh strings or how to dna
sequences are compared and what are we
and
understanding by comparing uh two dna
sequences or multiple more than two dna
sequences and etcetera etcetera and you
will also have
some introduction to um visualization
and exploration exploratory analysis
that will explore uh patterns in the
data again you can
for example visualize the data in the
form of heat map or in the form of a
filed
a scatter plot or in
in box plot as i actually as as we went
through and etc
so um
you will again
yeah this is advanced visualization in
in r where you can not only employ uh
basic rs functions to uh visualize the
data you can also use advanced
visualization methods using dedicated
packages like gg plot or gg45
so that the output that you are getting
is is of publication quality and this of
research sharing for the quality so um
you will also be introduced again to uh
different dimensionality reduction
techniques and how we can use these uh
principal component analysis and other
dimensionality production techniques to
explore more about the data to
understand patterns in the data and to
identify outliers that that could uh
actually
hinder our downstream analysis and
etcetera you can learn a lot from these
exploratory analysis and preprocessing
of the
data
and then you can proceed uh further by
by
employing the data into different
statistical analysis again you can
perform
factor regression analysis or
differential gene expression analysis in
the in the event of transcriptomics data
to understand uh gene expression
patterns that are different in
for example in cells in an altered state
or in a disease state compared to cells
that are in normal condition
and um
yeah
and we will again proceed to uh
different
machine learning
methods like supervised and unsupervised
analysis and how you can
prepare the data for these analysis
methods and and
what are the different parameters that
one needs to keep in mind for
employing these methods to
biological data because that that
actually changes
biological data is slightly little bit
different from um
normal like economics data and other
internet of things data that is used
generally more we used for
machine learning analysis and artificial
intelligence and data science methods
analysis and what are the
key um
parameter settings and assumptions that
we need to
understand and that we need to consider
while i'm employing these methods for
big data or onyx data
we can again
compare
or we can evaluate the performances of
unsupervised and supervised machine
learning models using different
evaluation metrics
and
comparative visualization
of
unsupervised analysis by comparing uh
the patterns that it
discovers with the patterns that is
already uh with the different
phenotypical characters that that is
associated with the data set
so this again uh this program will um
conclude uh
with a very uh detailed an example a
research project on um
applying for example r and different
libraries of r for
understanding metagenomics data analysis
in the context of a role of high fat
diet on obesity so you will be
introduced to
what is the data about and how did we
get this structured data and what is the
intended analysis and what is the
hypothesis
or what are we expecting to find what is
the aim of this analysis
in this project and then you will also
be introduced to different packages and
different
data formats and
how to use different these packages and
what are the considerations that you
have to consider while performing this
analysis
and
in the end you can
actually um
you will have a lot of discussions on
what are the biological implications of
the these different analysis methods and
the results that it produces and how
that
will and how that relates to the actual
finding of the paper and
generic understanding of how meta
genomics analysis uh for such a uh
such a
question or such a biological uh
research question uh works and uh
yeah uh you will also be given
access to a collab notebook that will
that will have a collection of all these
codes to perform this analysis and
you can yeah you can use these notebooks
for uh
for for the assignments that we are
sharing and for uh comparing different
methodologies or comparing different
data sets that we can uh take from
publicly available resources for
uh big data or big data
so yeah that will
conclude today's session on my
my session on
on introducing you to the curriculum of
uh
getting started with bioinformatics in r
and python and i will be happy to take
some questions if you have and i take
this opportunity to thank and i look
forward to meet
all of you in the program and
i hand over the podium now to sonalika
by the way
thank you so much dr raghav for the
detailed explanation of each and every
session that would be covered in the
getting started with the bioinformatics
and python and our programs and now if
there are any questions please put them
in the chat box so that we can take them
in the meantime let me share my screen
yes you can
put your question in the chat box
i can see rk has raised his hand you
want to ask something
uh hello there i'm audible
yes you are uh yeah i just wanted to
know that uh what is actually the
like the difference between like uh the
courses that you offer on the website
like the basic starter and those
the paid ones and like this program that
we are going to attend
can you just brief me about that
yes definitely i can all right so uh
you can see my screen right yeah
so what is the difference uh in a
program and the coursework that is up
there so what happens in the starter
subscription with which the users get
the access to the various courses that
are up there on the portal you get the
access to the coursework but what you
not get is the uh mental guidance right
so you are supposed to go through these
resources at your own pace all by
yourself and when you become a part of
an online mentor guided training program
itself that we have uh sessions where
you can take your questions from the
mentors and
we'll be having live sessions or the
recorded sessions where the mentor will
be taking you through the code
themselves and um help you
understand the code blocks and
various things like
working with your data set processing
normalization visualization etc etc and
help you clarify your questions
that's it and uh the so this major
difference actually plays a very big
role because
when users work with their code blog
they get stuck and having a mental
guidance helps them
proceed forward
does that make sense is it clear to you
i don't know i mean sorry
you have put a very short form
all right
and monday is asking how can we download
the r and python
okay so uh
mantra i'll just come back to you back
to your question
uh monday the first thing is that we'll
be yes taking you definitely through how
to install rn python and to understand
that you can simply go through the very
first lessons of rn python
works
the first lesson is free and it will
help you
go through
this lesson and install
rstudio right
go to this first lesson you have all the
details on how you have to download the
rstudio
and here it is installation of our this
will help you
and for python you can work with jupyter
notebooks it's not important that you
really have to download it and also to
mention here though dr raghav has
already mentioned but still i mentioned
it once again that the best thing about
the portal is that when you have to
learn about the syntax of
doing various things with your data set
it's that you can go through the code
block here and then practice it here in
the console itself you need not download
our studio for the practice file but yes
when you're working on a project and
have your own date on own data set it's
definitely easy to have the hour story
and then work with it
uh okay
now coming to mahindra's
question
i would like dr raghav to actually
answer this question dr raghav i'll put
it in your personal chat mahindra is
asking
uh
how can
i expect higher package and career
growth after taking this particular
program
when
uh you will i mean yeah
you will learn uh
coding first if you are if you have some
uh if you have introduction to coding
and if you have um
the logic uh behind
different analysis methods and can
understood these methods and we will
introduce you to uh different tools that
are necessary to perform
or mix data analysis in in r or python
so uh first you will have uh
you will have
developed a skill set for uh omix data
analysis in r let's say and uh not only
uh like loading the data and then just
opening it up but
like performing the necessary analysis
that will culminate into a research
paper and
by discussing different uh example
projects we will make you understand
the methodologies that are usually
discussed when uh in in bioinformatics
projects and bioinformatics research
papers are that
that um
analyzes big on its data so once you
have uh acquired the necessary
understanding to for example
[Music]
to understand different methods that are
used in research papers or for example
different
codes that are actually available a lot
in the support groups and you can take
those codes understand
different parts of the code just like
learning the code process and then
modify it and tweak it so that you can
perform that analysis for your dataset
so you have essentially
started with
exploring r as a tool to
using rs and analysis methods and
different methods to
perform analysis for yourself so that is
a skill development and
this will actually help you
in um
in for example
gaining a domain knowledge in
bioinformatics like once you have
acquired this skill and then after going
through several
research papers that does similar
bioinformatics analysis then you have
you will be developing a deeper
understanding in the domain itself in
how such analysis methods can new uh can
help you
ask relevant questions and answer
relevant questions with these analysis
methods so
that okay you have eight years of
experience in u.s healthcare and how can
i expect higher packaging
you can add one more skew to your uh
level and then with your experience then
your experience in uh
in your in in
introduction of getting familiarized to
different
data types for example you can apply or
take these
methods to
for different analysis for application
of uh
machine learning and other tools
um healthcare data so that you can get a
deeper understanding
of uh the patterns in the healthcare
data so application of machine learning
and ai tools to health care data is is
really hot now and how you can integrate
these different and health informatics
data with big data big data
bioinformatics is is also very
rapidly developing
field so
i think uh
yeah you can gain a lot from these
programs and and
that will
really be a good addition to your uh
yeah to your experience
and um
yeah and to your general uh uh
expanding of your horizons in the
bioinformatics analysis of the knowledge
of uh bioinformatics data analysis or
big data
bioinformatics
so hope i think i have
answered part of your queries and
convinced you that
you will gain a lot more
knowledge by
getting through or by
signing up for this package
any other questions thank you so much
yes thank you so much and uh myndra is
asking about uh placements after
completion of the course and paid
internship paid internships yes we can
definitely guide you about the same
after completing the coursework but uh
it's just uh or like a week 15 days long
program so uh definitely after like just
a 15 days
long program what you can expect is um
maybe a job position with the required
skill set that we can um tell you about
so yes after the program we'll
definitely have a session where we can
discuss about various opportunities that
you can
leverage after getting some good
hands-on with r or python whichever
course or program you pick
yes so now it's time that i take you all
through the registration part of this
particular program
so here is the program page for getting
started with r
and
once you are here on the program page if
you scroll
down
you will be able to look at the schedule
so the schedule that dr raghav discussed
with us it's mentioned here on which
date which particular topic would be
covered and what all uh coding lessons
are you supposed to go through as a part
of each and every session has been
mentioned as well
and you can go through this particular
uh page to get more insights about the
schedule and then if you scroll uh below
you'll
be able to look at three different
subscription levels beginner
intermediate and advanced and you you
can pick the level that um works the
best for you
and uh those who are in um different
countries and not us maybe you can
convert it to your own currency by
multiplying with the conversion and then
look at the amount right
all right so now what are these
different subscription levels all about
in the beginner subscription level you
will get the access to such sessions
like the way we just had today a group
session that the mentor uh today the
mentor did just explain about the
program what will be covered what it is
all about otherwise we'll be having the
uh the topics covered for each and every
session in
in the intermediate subscription level
you will get um an access to also the
one-on-one mentor support along with
these group sessions that we would be
having and in the advanced level you
will get some extra time to work with
the mentor to frame a research question
or have a research proposal in hand it
could help you if if it's a requirement
for you to submit a proposal maybe for
your higher studies or your next um job
position
right or you want to get started with a
research project but you are not sure uh
what like what exactly you should be
working on so you will get this extra
time to work on your research proposal
and get started with the research
project right so that is the the
difference the main difference between
these three different subscription
levels pick the one that works the best
for you
and once you have uh subscribed to this
program page after it you will be able
to find all the session recordings here
on the page itself now let's say you
were not able to attend a particular
session so you can get back to to this
program page and just go through the
recording and take your questions in the
slack channel so each and every
participant of the program
gets a chance to become a part of our uh
bioinformatics community and we have
specific assigned groups for each and
every program in our slack community so
you join the slack group and you take
your questions from the mentors in the
group itself after watching the
recording and uh that will help you out
and also before each and every session
you want the zoom link we'll mail you
the zoom link as well
and if our mail
goes to your promotions box let's say
first of all don't forget it to um
just shift it to your main primary inbox
otherwise you can also look at the zoom
link here uh under each and every
session as well and along with this
particular program you will get the
access to work on um
two of the main courseworks with r and
that is by info and r and bio ml uh
r
and talking about the python pro
program page now um daniel you can't
find the find that page which page this
page it's in the chat
if you click on it you'll be able to
open it
all right
now the second uh program getting
started with buying smart it's in python
so uh let me
send the link of this page in the chat
as well i'll also uh mail the links of
these pages to everyone and also i'll
tell you how you can go to these pages
directly from the portal
okay so uh the same thing if you scroll
down you'll be able to look at the
session details in here on which all
dates
like what exactly are we going to cover
the same thing that you'll be able to
also find the zoom links here before
each and every session and a recording
after each and every session
and if you scroll down the subscription
levels have been uh defined here as well
for the program pick the one that works
best for you i've already explained the
difference between the subscription
levels uh if there is any doubt in it
please you can put in the chat box and
i'm here to answer your question
and in the python program you will get
the access to by info and python uh
coursework and by ml using python
all right
now just to
uh tell you how you can go through these
particular
programs if you lose track of the links
just go to learn.org
uh
portal and then click on the programs
tab
here you can simply
type r
and this is the page that you want to go
to
and
pick your subscription
all right
and after you take your subscription you
want to follow the recordings and also
the resources again the same thing go to
the programs just type in our python and
here is your page
okay
that was about